40 days to go day 51 40 days to go on
the 90 day challenge in learning korean
40 days that's almost six weeks almost
six weeks that's not a lot of time
however
i am confident i feel good today and
i'll tell you why because
and it and i guess my experience of the
last couple of days has confirmed that
the major factor in language learning is
interest
you have to be interested interested in
the language interested in the content
in the lessons you're doing you have to
be interested interest means enjoyable
and
now i have received my second transcript
of the
kim jung-ha podcast
and so i've now gone through the first
one i'm starting the second one and you
know there's a total of 53 episodes in
his podcast i don't know if they will
all be transcribed i don't know if i'll
have time to study them all but i have
enough content there interesting content
to keep me going
um the first one was about uh
it's it's about him and books that he
reads and he discusses books
yukio mishima's the golden pavilion was
the first one the second one is jd
salinger the catcher in the rye and
there's 53 so i don't know how many
different works he's going to talk about
in korean
and it's going to be great uh i mean i
may lose interest in it as i go along
but for the time being
uh that's looking promising and then i
discovered in our library at link oh i
should add that we're going to be adding
those to our library at link
and when i've got five or six or seven
i'm in there
i'm going to uh mr kim and i'm gonna say
look uh first of all here are the
transcripts so you can use them if he
has any use for them and here's what
we've done and if he has no objections
then we will
continue to load them up and if he says
no i don't want you to do that then
we'll have to take them down
so that's what we're going to do
but i also discovered in our library
a movie someone had uploaded a movie
called the 200 pound beauty movie so the
movie's there and the audio and the text
and so if i get tired of the uh
you know the somewhat dryer if you want
uh podcast on literature i can then go
into the movie so i've got enough what
looks to be enough interesting content
and there's other stuff in our library
uh i can always go back to reading the
chosen elbow there's no audio there i
got enough to keep it going so i know
that that whereas i was concerned with
korean that i wouldn't find enough
interesting content i now got more than
enough
an embarrassment of riches as we say the
only thing that's holding me back
is the russian
because this whole issue surrounding the
crime the crimean problem the ukrainian
problem which is not very much fun if
you're sitting in kiev or donetsk or or
the crimean worrying about your future
but it is an interesting
phenomenon to follow and there's so much
different news and commentary and and
stuff
and um you know and it also i'll just
finish on that you know we've got such a
great community at link um
i'm gonna be talking to two korean
members tomorrow
uh evgeny from st petersburg and then
elena from ukraine over the weekend
they're members who have created content
for us in russian on everything from
daily life to grammar to you name it
and they're very helpful and nice people
but i'm talking to sergey who lives in
belarus who's studying uh he speaks a
number of languages english german i
can't remember them all who's studying
italian
and he says you know i'm looking for a
kind of uh uh
interesting content that's not too
difficult have you got any suggestions
and i said well you should really try
the aleotto de la sera
from radio do an italian in italy
because they have these wonderful
podcasts on history and art and so many
different things
and so long behold i'm sitting at my
desk at five in the evening which is
probably six in the morning his time
and i get a little note my skype note
pops up in italian he says i've found
the alioto de la sera it's from i can
understand most of it you know grazia
thank you and stuff like that that's our
community people helping each other
uh sharing content uh for example i have
my discussion with sergey for half an
hour at the end of it he writes down all
of the phrasing that i got wrong
and then he records it that's six
minutes of recording of him reading all
those phrases that i got wrong so that i
can study them and listen to it
and and learn from it so so this is the
world of language learning today people
from belarus russia brazil japan china
whatever sharing their language their
experience helping each other cheering
each other on i get statements on on my
wall at link you know thanking me first
of all that finally language learning
has become enjoyable congratulating me
for
i reached a milestone in korean in terms
of
known words and stuff this is the world
my classroom is the world
it's amazing so i feel very positive
and uh tonight i get the the vancouver
cox are on tv they'll get beaten again
so that'll dampen my mood a bit but
right now it's it's i'm very glad that i
have a lot of fascinating content ahead
of me so i think the next 40 days
i'll be able to make some progress